hello friends I'm a lot of welcome to my
channel what today you are watching an
outrageous gameplay video sponsored by
Square Enix I got to play this game
lowest week at an event with my friends
Andrea and Andy I will leave links in
the description below to way you can
find those too if you would like to one
really cool thing about this is that
this is the first PlayStation 5 game
I've played it is coming to next-gen
Xbox next-gen Playstation also current
gen and PC
we were playing on PCs but I decided to
play controller and you'll kind of see
why this game basically plays a lot like
Gears of War I will have a full like
much more opinion critical based preview
up on the inside gaming YouTube channel
but basically if you aren't familiar
with outriders it is a three person
co-op sci-fi shooter it is made by
Studio who's worked on kids before they
made Bulletstorm too but then it also
has like destiny elements and division
elements and you'll see some of that in
this gameplay but it is really pretty
and I hope this is what it looks like on
next-gen consoles it was very exciting
to get to play something that's coming
out on on PS 5 and Xbox Series X so yeah
I don't know the specs of the PC that I
played on but I was definitely impressed
ok that's enough enjoy the gameplay wow
you guys oh hey cuties what good friends
come on I love it we all have these
tight pants on I also just want you know
it's really important excuse me can you
guys please just collect and listen the
earrings I have are an accident it was
not a style choice I made intentionally
I'm really sorry about it you're like a
daddy Santa thank you ok I really want
to figure out what my ability actually
does let me find out right oh Jesus
so I do like a ground oh my god I'm
gonna whoa did you do that Andrea I'm
not sure ok trying not to hit you but
you're on close range
damn Andrea that was thick that that I
did yeah that was dub huge fan big fan
II a walk
movie throwing these grenade stuff level
3 gamer alright okay and a lot of those
earrings don't look that cool okay I
know they don't all right okay hey I got
new pants you guys I now have a rituals
like the awakened yeah more pockets oh
yeah armor 69 nice nice nice nice 64 I'm
a tank
Oh mines 116 so you guys where did you
go I don't have quality my people on
fire so I mean a good point a good point
are you ready to go boys where we drop
in oh I hit that I hit the button hang
on hang on restocking his ammo over here
you didn't see that weight already I
didn't yep yep I want some ammo oh and
we're already in hub though we can't
really you can go back and read it you
just hit the back button oh it's so you
know you guys I'm gonna have to ask you
to pay for my chiropractic fees because
I feel like I'm really putting a team
over back here Wow
pounds warehouse I think they have dogs
I feel like my man is giving me real
Jason Momoa vibes and I didn't do that
on purpose
everything about Oh
well well well that guy was just doing
his job though yeah yeah but he could
have done it with a smile okay you're
right he did deserve it so I'm gonna hit
this I'm gonna hit my to skill and I
rock up whoa
I'm like the theme look at me oh wow
yeah what's up here you guys proud of me
oh yeah thank you are you that is that's
what kind of game you are any you need
like positive feedback at regular
interval I'm glad you're catching up I
got it got it
okay let's take a look at what I got
here okay okay very cool
I suspect we all got the same thing I do
like the whole you got a crusty coat
excellent
oh the hood covers my terrible is thank
God I'll never let anybody so you have
weird earrings all right okay you know I
don't know what weird but all right oh
yeah luck stability three what does it
do we just come to the same oh wait why
did you just go what just happened
[ __ ] and yes plain yourself oh oh yes
hang on what does mine idiot okay
confirm let's do this oh you have you
have you have like electricity hands you
got like electric gloves own glow
brighter it looks like how did you how
do you get the paws Andrea on controller
half up on the d-pad got it it reminds
me of fable tooth anyone anyone just me
anyone when I think of failure I just
think of Milo the Xbox 360 demo like I
just think of well you might be a
novelist and I was like why did he
attached himself to a fable for it
that's weird
a lot of white supremacy Wow
yeah what you drinking there friends a
little Chardonnay
how is the Chardonnay is at night it's
nice it is nice yeah yeah I'm like I'm
drinking that oh no oh you're actually
drinking Chardonnay right now and yeah
they have a bar did you miss
you look so intensely at Regis than you
would [ __ ] you want to take a quick
break to go get a drink
well now the boy is gone you want to
talk about tampons like what brands do
you like so I've heard that all the rage
is getting sucked yeah about like taking
it in and out of my vagina every thanks
Andy Andy Court says everybody thanks
for nothing Andy not that I asked you I
love it in the room that I'm in because
my hair is white everyone just has quite
slash gray hair like oh you guys made
this for me thank you I'm accepted yeah
oh wait none don't slow Cortese over
here where did you say automatic shotgun
yeah where was that
oh it too late oh absolutely Obama I
will take this uh yeah we're close man
yeah I was running out of sniper ammo oh
that's a woman in the future it's all
fluid alone oh yeah Oh talk to him - oh
[ __ ] yeah I thought you would pull me
into the cutscene no okay it's all right
Interactive don't spoil I died oh sorry
my bad I got shot in the head again
Audrey Oh Keanu Reeves wow I can't
believe they made another statement
about abortion in this super with rave
who says politics can't be in game all
right
Audrey I got your back she just dropped
the n-word Wow oh my god that is yeah we
all like it and no one can see our
earrings I mean my earrings the shotgun
is is very good and also very Gears of
War and I love it
that's my PSA oh wow all right
okay fire for everybody yeah this [ __ ]
roll
oh that's a lot of grenades okay well
good good
oh I saw skeletons yeah that's what my
ability does skele Phi's them there is
definitely an interesting balance in the
same trying to encourage you to get
close quotas and use melee and also like
range because of the couple it's like
two very different playstyles merged
with the abilities versus weapons it's
interesting yeah it's super super
conflicting but also interested there
are I think I'm I'm I'm enjoying that
conflict yeah
I walk through the door I have cutscene
I see the dude oh this boy is big Oh
ah ah who did that honey I just meal
ideas meal exactly oh um works
I got a heal up a bit oh goodness
interesting choice covering is armor and
fabric hey this is my first time
equipping something that isn't like
rusty are all you guys wow I'm really
moving on up in the world still no
skills still no skills okay
if you tab is also go down the hill yeah
so um Annie you're the only one on a
keyboard so if you could shut the [ __ ]
out with your assistance drugs
that'd be great I'm here me to it I'm
not getting anything
yeah so just follow me alright okay okay
so there's a guy on a minigun I'm gonna
try to take out okay and we sound like
III president presenters right now or
like we're on stage please yeah there's
a guy on the left
oh nice shot man oh you're really
playing now huh yeah okay guys I'm gonna
flank right
Oh chichi Roger Roger that was [ __ ]
maybe one of you covers the other yep I
love that from you and you know great
gamers that's great well a gamer oh you
both lifted me that was very sweet
look at us being a team look at us what
a thought Judas ah not me I see a green
lid over here hold on me go get it scrap
haven't seen anything so far bad I think
I did just directly follow Andrea in a
loop which probably isn't the most
efficient means of discovery that's fine
but I have I have a cool new facemask do
you
cool confront the altar at the tower I
never wanted anything bad I want to
confront this before we go in there look
at there's some boxes over here we
should probably ammo up no I love box
right I look like it Jedi what do you
keep getting a healthy girl it's not
here
all right in the doll I got a helmet but
you know what I'm not gonna use it
helmets a full Eames you know I really
like the hood better out of my face I
always put the helmet riding on it alone
what does he just haven't gotten [ __ ]
they look sad I don't want in the looks
place the lamps I am NOT a lame clearly
no you what a lame it looks good I
really like my dick amar I have on my
britches huh you do have a cup on ya
gotta keep the good safe you know how it
be I do know her oh hey big boy okay
look exactly what I look like without a
shirt on
yeah what don't agree veins
you got like a bony protrusion yeah it's
my back knee people think I have boobs
but really it's just a protruding
ribcage yeah bras really hope around
that out
oh is this oh cool Oh Calipari [ __ ] oh I
think he teleport
right okay you don't have to like yell
about it
all right electricity really everywhere
it'd be everywhere
yeah you really have to utilize the
Dodge yeah thanks Ubisoft yeah you
really got to utilize your abilities man
when I stop sick dodge roll view when
you get close to him he yells too close
it's great I love it
fells like my grandpa
your grandmother made some peach pie
lunatic thanks grandpa
I don't think Shakira should have done
that at the Super Bowl
yeah oh we stopped up you so dad daddy
kids mother died
hey you're so [ __ ] bad dude [ __ ]
good job humor yeah we're real gamers oh
wow we'd play a video game